basic core argument of why we love
America shouldn't be political which is
the American founding was an
unbelievable unique moment in human
history because it was reliant on some
classical observations of human nature
that made claims against tyranny in the
pursuit of Liberty that believing not in
sectarianism or tribalism but instead in
the individual and the Dignity of the
individual that is you can disagree with
this but the founders largely believed
that it was made in the image of the
Divine therefore there's worth and
there's Dignity of that person you don't
have to accept that but at least you can
accept the idea that you know the
individual is Sovereign and matters and
then you build a system around that that
has turned into the most amazing Society
ever to exist and now we're deciding to
end that